the man who became famous for saying
you're fired is facing what could be the
most serious and consequential personnel
decision of his life tonight both
supporters and detractors of President
Trump are now openly talking about what
might happen if the president decides to
pull the plug on the investigation being
conducted by special counsel robert
muller the talk on Capitol Hill comes as
the president lashes out about a Monday
raid directed at his longtime personal
attorney all of this of course as the
president of the United States also
prepares to decide about possible US
military action against Syria for
chemical attacks there another busy news
night here on special report we begin
again on the North Lawn with chief White
House correspondent John Roberts even
John brick at evening to you the raid on
the president's personal attorney
Michael Cohen's two offices his
residence and his temporary hotel room
represents a steep escalation of the
Russia investigation by the Justice
Department one that President Trump has
taken as a personal affront and left
uncertain what he plans to do next thank
you very much everybody
asked again whether President Trump had
any thoughts or intentions about firing
Robert Muller for the first time today
the press secretary did not issue a
denial you have said several times from
the podium that the president has
neither the intention nor is thinking
about firing Robert Moore what does that
remain the case today this question
directly last night and I'd refer you
back to his comments what the president
said last night was sharply different
than what he has said in the past when
he has insisted he was not going to fire
more fire well I think it's a disgrace
what's going on we'll see what happens
sources close to the president say they
don't believe he'll fire Muller Senate
Judiciary Committee Chairman Chuck
Grassley today said it would be a
terrible idea it would be suicide
for the president to want to talk about
fire and mauler but in the event
President Trump wanted to fire Muller
the White House made it clear he has the
power to do so but I don't have any
further announcements no question the
president is livid about the FBI raids
on his personal attorney Michael Cohen
sources say the FBI took air
in Cowen's possession including
privileged documents and communications
computers and cell phones president
Trump warned last year that Robert
molars investigation should not stray
outside its mandate to say an attack on
our country in a true sense it's an
attack on what we all stand for to hear
the press secretary tell it president
Trump now believes Muller has crossed a
line the president has been clear that
he thinks that this has gone too far the
Senate Minority Leader heaped criticism
on the president's complaints today
insisting the raid was signed off on by
a number of officials who president
Trump appointed President Trump believes
this to be a partisan conspiracy he once
again ignores the fact every major
player is a Republican it's still
unclear what the FBI was looking for
bank fraud regarding the payment to
stormy Daniels has been suggested
sources tell FOX News Cohen paid Daniels
from an existing home equity line of
credit and that he didn't need to tell
the bank what the money was for the
$130,000 was then transferred to an LLC
solely owned by Cohen and from there
wired to an attorney in Beverly Hills
president Trump denies any knowledge of
the transaction
President Trump is also weighing options
to respond to the suspected chemical
attack in Syria
puddling last night with his national
security team talking with French
president Emmanuel macron and British
prime minister Theresa May the president
today cancelled his weekend trip to Peru
in Colombia
indicating a response could come toward
the end of the week we're gonna continue
to work with a number of our partners
and allies as we determine what the next
best steps are defense secretary James
Madison also canceled weekend plans to
travel to Nevada and San Francisco in
order to be ready at a moment's notice
to respond to the president's call we
also have heard that that while the
United States and its allies are still
working to confirm whether in fact
chemical weapons were used in the attack
the White House remains confident that
they were the press secretary Sarah can
be Sanders again saying today that the
White House is fully confident with what
it is said so far on the matter
Brett John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thanks